today we will be detonating an in-bomb a
dark matter bomb even a supernova it
gets so crazy you can't even fathom it
but first we're going to start off with
a 50 000 tnt n-bomb explosion good luck
the bomb drops in 10 seconds come on
llama let's go where's all the water
where do i hide oh i'm gonna die i'm
gonna die i'm gonna die yo i'm a genius
i think i have a safe spot five four
three go to the ground go chris go go go
it's about to explode
oh my gosh it's just spitting out tnt
did we win congratulations you all
survived this next map we have a giant
parkour vending machine which sounds
really cool doesn't it yeah except for
the part that there's giant sam missiles
they're gonna be shooting you the entire
way you're going up and if you die you
have to eat mustard
i'm going i didn't say start you just
said it you just set it low turn on the
sand missiles what are you doing
missiles fire
oh my gosh i hate everyone here
why did i start so late
what
what happened
carl it's close oh oh it's coming down
the water coral
oh no
dude you guys are slow let's go
the only one to survive was chandler
chris here's a spoon of mustard
my tongue shriveled up like spongebob
i'm about to drop 250 000 tons of tmt on
top of you and if you die we're gonna
pelt you of babies what like actual
babies all right go ahead and start
running
thanks for the jump boost oh there it is
get away
i'm literally still under it we're so
dead
i was one block
away i was one block away
oh my god baby barrage on three three
all right that's good enough this map
has a 500 000 tnt tornado
it's right behind me why is it following
me if you don't survive you have to do
50 push-ups carl you need to go quicker
dog
it's chasing me
oh oh carl
what was i supposed to do
all right the strategy is to get high
ow
how am i taking damage
wait oh
it spawned on me
come on dirt the tnt spawned on me chris
can you do 50 push-ups no i cannot i'm
still alive i'm still alive
i picked the one spot where the tnt
didn't fall congratulations
chris and chandler are surviving carl
let's do some push-ups all right let's
go
49 50.
it only took him five minutes and now
we're in the middle of the bikini bottom
and now we're gonna nuke it what this
has the blast of over 1 million tnt and
if you die this time you have to do the
next challenge standing in a trash can
did we get even time to
hide i'm gonna hide under his pp under
patrick's peepee ah tnt ripens up
it blew me off the map what what we had
no time to hide if you guys would have
went into the pineapple and went on the
second floor you would have survived
that one was rigged the independence day
spaceship is gonna beam down five
million tnt all three of you are
standing in trash cans and you're
probably miserable yes my back hurts
instead of giving you a punishment this
time we're gonna give you a prize if you
don't die i'll give your father a brand
new iphone 13. my dad can't even use one
let's go
oh my god this is a dead end
oh dear god
all right i think i'm good here
i'm hiding under this lamp mr beast
burger it needs to be safe if the laser
destroys mr beast burger i'm canceling
the spaceship
what
oh
i did it i picked the one building it
didn't hit look the city looks like it
got pixelated can i get out the trash
can yeah you can get out the trash can
just give me your dad's addresses i'll
shoot them all at iphone 13. okay my dad
lives at we discovered a secret military
base buried deep inside the
mountainsides and conveniently i parked
a giant submarine right outside of it
equipped with a bunch of nukes
equivalent to 10 million minecraft tnt
and gentlemen if you die you have to
call your mom tell her you're a loser
and then hang up we're literally not
going to survive as if she doesn't
already know you already know chandler
you already know wait you guys are
hiding under the tank heck no i'm going
to the torpedo they wouldn't destroy
themselves
all right here it comes oh guys you guys
are done for under this tank
what the heck you like chris oh
they're shooting right at me i think
carl might have had the big brain idea
i'm just watching the nukes shoot the
other direction i think it's coming this
way changing oh my god big fat boy
big fat boy i'm running
oh my god oh it's playing tnt
oh my god it got so close to me i
survived we're getting better at this
this is what it looked like before the
project here's what it looked like after
every explosion up to this point in the
video combined is only 20 the size of
what you're about to see and if you
don't survive you have to drink a
blended up mcdonald's burger hey you
like mcdonald's there better not be
pickles
run go
i'm leaving the stupid town oh my god i
can hear it i can hear it jesus christ
oh no
i'm already
what bruh
[Applause]
oh that looks so gross
[Music]
you guys are currently standing on earth
and i planted a dark matter bomb in the
core of the planet and if you somehow
don't die to this dark matter bomb i'll
give you a hundred thousand dollars in
cash what i see it's impossible it's not
impossible but it's 99 you're gonna die
[Music]
i already fell you fell oh
[Music]
i didn't know the world was hot chandler
you should go it's like literally right
under you
oh oh all right the dark matter bombs
expanding taylor ask the black hole if
it won't consume you please stop and now
the world is consumed by a giant dark
matter bomb
next planet this is a 1 billion tnt
supernova statistically you're not going
to survive so i'm gonna carry the prize
over if you survive this time i'll give
you a hundred thousand dollars give us
literally two minutes come on i actually
do have a plan you could go to a
different universe you're still dying i
believe i can do it i have a plan can i
get a pickaxe guys the supernova cold it
wants to blow things up uh wrong number
sorry oh there she is whistling in my
ear one billion tnt supernova hundred
thousand dollars online for the boys no
i'm going full sweat mode oh it's
getting so bright it's dusty i'm burning
holy cow what i caught on fire i can't
see anything even i can't see what does
that mean wait the whole map is gone the
entire universe is gone and all of you
died if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button i hope you enjoyed the
video goodbye